how are you doing
hey i'm good thank you i'm in atlanta i
finished in a week
um which is very exciting yeah it'd be
my last day on loki the day our second
episode airs so just very busy getting
it ready for television basically
i was gonna i was gonna say i think a
lot of people don't realize you're
probably still doing
final vfx on episode
yeah we're still doing like sound mix
vfx
music we're kind of getting everything
ready on episode six at the moment and
then yeah then i'm finished it's
it's so surreal it's really nice seeing
it go out into the world but
obviously it's been my life for two
years so you normally kind of get this
like morning period whenever you finish
something to be like oh i wonder but i
don't have time it's like now it's just
out there so
yeah so it's it's fun it's yeah been
quite a ride
i have a ton of questions for you first
i want to start with congratulations
first two episodes are fantastic cannot
wait to see the rest
of it uh but i am curious how much free
will do you think people have in the mcu
and how much is it sort of the time
keepers just saying this is what you're
going to be doing
well i would say that you know
everything is
dictated by the timekeepers so you know
that's kind of the discussion within our
show right like
mobius and loki have that conversation
like i love that line that loki has
he's like so really we're the only ones
with free will at the tva
because you know they're working for the
time keepers but
everybody else like you know on earth as
far as they're aware
they think they're living on that that
you know free will but really they're
not they're on the set path because if
they venture off it the tva are going to
come
so yeah completely how old do you think
mobius is i know that the tva moves in
different
speeds whatever but do you think there's
like an age if you were to quantify it
in human years
so i think he must be hundreds
quite a few hundred years old but maybe
not as old as we
it's so this is the way to explain it
because obviously the tva is outside of
space and time right so i think he must
be very
hundreds and hundreds of years old
because time doesn't affect him in the
same way as it would
is as if if he was on earth
but my theory is and this is not like
this is just me guessing
i think we're i don't know i just think
i'm just trying to work it out really
because i feel like he
i think quite a few hundred years old
would be my guest because him and ren
slayer had this really beautiful deep
friendship and like i think everyone at
the tva is like
you know arguably they're all from the
beginning of time
because the timekeepers brought them
into existence so i think it's sort of
almost unknowable
for us to i mean i'm so bad at maths i
think it's almost unknowable for us to
work out how old he possibly could be
so it must be more than hundreds
actually so the first episode 50 minutes
second episode is 53 are the rest of the
episodes similar in length
yeah they kind of vary i think we we we
basically kind of did what was best for
the story
but they're all kind of around that
ballpark i would say more or less
sure i'm curious how it works though
with um
deleted scenes in a series like this do
you actually end up with a lot of stuff
on the cutting room floor and
if so is there any thought process about
how fans will eventually see it
sure um i think for i mean
it's like everything right there
definitely a scenes across the show that
we didn't end up putting in there just
because once you're in the edit right
like
when you're cutting sometimes there'll
be a scene where you're like oh actually
this is actually slowing the story down
and not pushing us forwards or
it you know sounds like tonally it
doesn't quite sit right so i think
that's just the nature of filmmaking so
in terms of the fan seeing any i guess
that would probably be more in marvel's
hands
um what they would want to release from
the cutting room floor but
yeah i mean we definitely have moments
that you know we've
shifted and changed but just sort of
just in the nature of filmmaking really
there's a cool shot of tom and owen
walking i think it's episode one when
they look out over the city
and you know that city is a big
establishing shot for the tva and this
entire society
can you sort of talk about the debate on
what that shot was going to look like
and putting that shot together yeah so
i had a lot of fun actually like with
the team like coming up the idea of the
tva because it's like
i would say that that city shot is
really inspired by the comics right
where they have the rows of desks that
stretch out into infinity and that's
definitely something
i know me and my production designer
took a lot of inspiration from and you
can see that across other spaces in the
tva the idea of this
infinite amount um but along with that i
think the real challenge was
okay so we're setting up somewhere that
exists outside of time
and space and there's no sun and it's
not really in a space so it's kind of a
way to show that
in a way that people could you know wrap
their head around i think that's
shot there it's almost like a an office
that is a city really so it was kind of
explaining that but they're having it
stretch off into infinity i mean
i always think about it in a weird way
almost a bit like las vegas
like you know the they don't take many
breaks in the tva i think we have one
poster in episode two that says they get
a 17-minute lunch break but
we don't get the impression that any of
these people sleep you know because they
don't need to
like i said like time is very different
within the tva so they're always working
hence why
mobius's exact age would be unknowable
because how could we know
it's from whenever the timekeepers you
know began the tva
so yeah it's a lot to wrap your head
around
i'm always curious like all marvel fans
about easter eggs are there any specific
scenes
in the first two episodes that you would
advise
fans to hit pause on
oh just trying to honestly i would say
like
these are more just fun details but the
drink that mobius is drinking in the
time theatre scene
is like a drink that's not around
anymore and we've got a lot of fun stuff
like that across the tva
like stuff that doesn't necessarily
exist within
you know our time now on earth like but
you know the tva you can get that kind
of stuff which i think is fun
um i also have a few references to
marvel across it like there's a shop
that's an homage to iron man which i
think
any fan of iron man will probably spot
quite quickly
um so yeah those are the kind of things
but i wouldn't want to lead
the witness too much because i just
think it's fun to kind of spot that
stuff right so
yeah completely uh what was it like
actually the thing that i think one of
the things that i love about the series
the most is that you're exploring a new
part of the mcu something that's never
come before
and so what is it like as a director
establishing the rules and regulations
if you will
of this new organization and how much
freedom do you have versus
someone overseeing you at marvel saying
oh we got to be careful with this
honestly i think i've never felt like
with marvel it was always whatever's
best for story then we'll work it out
and i think
the really fun thing for us as a team in
creating the tva
was just i mean for me like i've worked
in a lot of offices
it took me a long time to get my first
directing gig and
i think something for me was like well i
want this to feel like a real living
breathing office so these guys like
never stop working there should be a
coffee pot that looks like it hasn't
been changed for
far too long and there should be posters
telling you to keep your desk tidy
and just the messiness and the realness
of the place like i was really keen to
explore that
and alongside that i think the fun of it
was like i was really
inspired by like brutalist architecture
because where i grew up in southeast
london like i grew up near where they
filmed a clockwork orange
and children and men and i just i love
the use of that and obviously blade
runner uses a lot of architecture like
that and i was excited by seeing that in
the mcu but mixing that with this kind
of midwest
you know very classy style because you
know the tv are very heroic and
the idea of melding those together was
really exciting to me
along with like um like i guess like the
retro futuristic technology like i was
really excited
in like working with russell bobber on
who's that who is our prop
like working on like the weapon design
and how the computers would look with
kazra my production designer and
i think something that was exciting to
me was just kind of pulling from all
these different areas of sci-fi like i
kind of wanted the show to almost be
like a big love letter to sci-fi like um
our time doors are inspired by dune for
example but we also have like
um the font on the computers was
inspired by alien
and so we were kind of you know we were
pulling from everywhere but i think with
all those sci-fi references
and the overall style reference it was
also just always about giving it a
groundedness and always the emotion is
what would ground us in the
you know the circumstances we were in so
like
for example as you see when loki's first
brought in by the tva
we really wanted that i mean for me i
wanted that to represent what it was
like going through the airport
you know and like having to go for all
the security changes and like all the
weird queues you have to go in or i
guess in america the dmv
so i think it was always trying to bring
like
bits of reality that the audience would
recognize um but putting that into a
fantastical setting
i have to stop there i just want to say
thank you so much for giving me your
time a million other questions for
another day
thank you so much all right thank you
cheers